à l'assemblée nationale ce matin les
députés ont poursuivi l'examen du projet
de loi sur l'interruption de la
grossesse avant de se prononcer sur une
motion de renvoi de monsieur de rome
député réformateur
un vote pourrait intervenir la nuit
prochaine hier trois interventions ont
été particulièrement remarquées selon
monsieur michel debré l'ancien premier
ministre
c'est le docteur pons députée udf du lot
et celle de jean pierre cot du parti
commence en nous pouvons faire de bonnes
lois nous pouvons constituer un pont
service social et les données en mode
elle passée de la répression aveugle à
l'absence totale de contraintes
c'est allé d'un excès à l'autre d'une
erreur grave à une autre erreur grave
c'est marqué une sorte d'application du
législateur devant la difficulté
ce que je propose affirmer le principe
du respect de la vie humaine
ensuite accueillir soutenir protéger
promouvoir la maternité qui sera le plus
souvent une maternité volontaire mais
qui doit être une maternité séconde
enfin déterminer les procédures
raisonnable mais exceptionnelle selon
lesquelles face à des détresses
dramatique
l'interruption de grossesse peut
seulement être autorisée
voilà qui eût été du bon travail
législatif quart sud est et du bon
travail social à la fois nationale et
humain
j'ai parlé mes chers collègues avec
mesure eu égard aux convictions de
chacun
eu égard à la personne du président de
la république
eu égard à vous même madame le ministre
mais je ne suis pas le seul sur les
rangs de cette assemblée a regretté une
grande occasion totalement manqué madame
votre courage et votre détermination
font l'admiration de vos amis comme de
vos adversaires
le fait qu'une femme soit venu ici porté
l'espoir de ces centaines de milliers de
femmes qui se soumettent de chaque année
à la mutilation soit venu faire cesser
ce drame de ces centaines de femmes qui
en france
meurt chaque année du fait des
avortements clandestins est en soi
quelque chose d'important que vous
madame
soyez venu ici témoigner et que vous
ayez mis votre volonté ou services de
cela je crois est un gage de réussite de
votre entreprise dans cette assemblée
d'hommes et tout à l'heure en écoutant
monsieur michel debré en regardant ce
qui la police et je cherchais les
applaudissements féminin je n'en
trouvais pas l'ordre national des
médecins n'est pas la représentation
exclusive de sony t médical l'ordre
national des médecins est une chapelle
avec un clergé mais qui n'a plus de
fidèles
je ne voudrais pas prolonger le débat
mais je crois que ces choses là devait
être dit je voudrais maintenant sortir
monsieur hamel je vous écoute toujours
avec la plus grande attention et avec
beaucoup de respect est ce que je dis je
le dis sans passion mais je le dis avec
ma conscience
je voudrais maintenant mes chers
collègues que nous sortions de cette
émission le 13 décembre 1973 monsieur
jean taittinger garde des sceaux de
l'époque nous disait il ya 1000
avortements clandestins tous les jours
et sur ces 1000 avortements il ya une
femme qui meurt depuis que monsieur le
garde des sceaux a prononcé ces paroles
ici même 349 jours se sont écoulés
il y a eu 3 149 1000 avortements
clandestins et 349 femmes sont mortes où
je sais que le malheur arrive toujours
aux autres
je sais que l'accident de la route
ce n'est jamais pour soi-même ou pour sa
propre famille mais songé un instant à
ces 349 femmes à leurs familles imaginez
quelle serait la réaction s'il
s'agissait de quelqu'un qui vous
touchent de près parleriez vous avec
autant de conviction de l'origine exacte
de la naissance de la vie